à activer leur caméra pour que nous
puissions le plaisir de vous voir à
l'écran et nous allons tout de suite
commencer ce tour de table avant de
passer tout à l'heure au bassin
Atlantique de la Somme
je ne sais pas si nous inviter et
participons ont entendu le message
visiblement c'est en cours
donc je vais vous donner quelques
minutes pour que vous puissiez tous vous
connecter
donc Mayotte Nouvelle-Calédonie
président de la Réunion également
je pense que Wallis et Futuna est
également présent
il va ce que je vous propose c'est de
pouvoir commencer maintenant pour qu'on
puisse tenir notre notre délai puisque
nous enchaînons tout à l'heure avec le
bassin atlantique mais chers collègues
dans le cadre de la préparation de notre
rapport sur l'évolution institutionnelle
des autres-mères en tant que
corps-à-porteur Michelin et moi-même
avons jugé utile d'entendre des acteurs
du monde économique ultramarin nous
allons ainsi échanger ce matin avec les
représentants des chambres de commerce
et d'industrie des CCI d'outre-mer
regroupés au sein de la césium laquelle
vient de désigner son nouveau président
Monsieur Pierrick Robert que je salue à
la Réunion ce président il nous feront
part de leur réflexion sur le bilan de
l'organisation institutionnelle de leur
territoire et sur le éventuel souhait
d'évolution du point de vue économique
et compte tenu du décalage horaire ne
commencerons par les CCI de l'océan
Indien et Pacifique puis comme je vous
l'ai indiqué tout à l'heure nous
passerons ensuite au bassin Atlantique
aux alentours de 11h je vais donc vous
donner la parole monsieur le Président
Mesdames Messieurs pour un tour de table
dans le cadre de votre exposé éliminaire
sur la base d'une trame qui vous a été
adressée par délégation et puis avec
Jacqueline Michelin Jacques pardon nous
vous interrogerons tout à l'heure sur un
certain nombre de questions pour pouvoir
donner un peu de rythme et de fluidité à
cette audition et surtout vous entendre
également sur le point de vue des
acteurs économiques sur ce sujet
d'intérêt pour vos territoires
respectifs ce Président vous avez la
parole
sur le président merci
je serai accompagné je pense qu'il est
aussi en ligne de Monsieur Pierre Dupuy
qui est le directeur de la Somme
pour cette audition donc monsieur le
Président Mesdames les sénatrice
monsieur les sénateurs
la question de la réforme
institutionnelle
que vous nous posez est au fond du
niveau celle du niveau approprié
d'élaboration des normes
est-ce que l'État est-ce que c'est
l'État qui doit adapter les normes ou
les autorités locales
pour y répondre les CCI d'outre-mer
par ne vous parleront bien évidemment
que de l'impact de ces normes et de leur
élaboration sur le développement
économique
voilà ce que je voulais
dire en préambule le
d'abord la vie des chefs d'entreprise
sont très différents
selon les territoires et notamment dans
l'article 74 il nous disent que leur loi
organique ont besoin d'être vu
dans l'article 73 s'il y a un fort
sentiment d'inadaptation des normes et
des modes d'intervention des pouvoirs
publics il y a aussi plusieurs
territoires dans plusieurs territoires
une forte inquiétude sur les risques
d'une évolution statutaire le
rattachement des territoires d'outre-mer
à la France
pour nous il y a trois choses examinées
l'opportunité la capacité des
collectivités à mettre en oeuvre de
nouvelles compétences et l'organisation
de ces nouveaux pouvoirs
comment se mettre en place
pour cette déclinaison qui doit avoir
lieu l'opportunité d'abord il n'y a pas
il n'y a notre connaissance jamais eu
d'études scientifiques
comparant l'impact des différentes
évolutions statutaires
sur leur trajectoire de développement
économique pourtant nous avons des cas
d'école assez intéressants avec des
territoires comme Mayotte ou les trois
saints qui ont changé de statut encore
assez récemment
nous considérons
il y a encore des incertitudes autour de
cette impact pour dire cela nous nous
appuyons principalement sur deux
éléments
le taux de croissance du PIB par
habitant entre 2000 et 2020 d'une part
et d'autre part le taux de croissance
annuel moyen de de l'indice de
développement humain en 2012 on était
que non seulement il n'y a pas de lien
apparent entre la vitesse de
développement d'un territoire et son
statut mais qu'en plus il n'y a pas de
changement substantiel des trajectoires
économiques des territoires lors d'un
changement statutaire au contraire nous
constatons que si certains territoires
bénéficiant de l'autonomie ont pu
connaître une amélioration significative
dans le de leurs économies je pense en
particulier
la Nouvelle-Calédonie tirée par le
nickel et à Saint Barthélemy qui a su
profiter de la situation particulière de
son marché lié au tourisme les
territoires ayant le moins d'autonomie
se développe globalement plus vite
si cependant une réforme devait être
menée te poserait à selon nous la
question des moyens alloués aux
collectivités pour la mettre en oeuvre
deux éléments dans ce sens d'abord les
régions ultramarines se caractérise par
des délais moyens de paiement aux
entreprises
deux fois supérieur au plafond l'ego
selon un rapport de l'Inspection
générale de l'administration en 2019
heureux enfonce un renforcement des
pouvoirs impliquerait donc une
augmentation de leur budget visiblement
contrainte pour leur permettre de les
exercer ensuite nous avons aussi regardé
les statistiques de la Direction
générale des collectivités locales sur
l'état de la fonction publique
territoriale on constate que à
l'exception de la Martinique toutes les
régions
ultramarines manque de cadres dans leur
fonction publique territoriale malgré
des effectifs au dessus de la moyenne
comment comme si une réforme devait être
menée pour donner plus de compétences
aux collectivités on devrait donc
penserment les renforcer en amont à
supposer enfin que cela arrive il
resterait une dernière question comment
organiser ces nouveaux pouvoirs et nous
semble important d'éviter la
concentration entre les mêmes pouvoirs
les mêmes mains des pouvoirs législatif
et exécutif
ce n'est pas qu'une vue de l'esprit le
premier rapport de l'Agence Française
anticorruption et du service statistique
des ministères du ministère de
l'Intérieur sur les atteintes de
probabilités publiques montrent que les
collectivités de l'article 74 concentre
3,5% des infractions pour
0,9% de la population et 0,6% du PIB ce
que l'agence française
anticorruption attributs à leur
singularité institutionnelle
si un nouveau système doit être conçu il
doit donc comprendre
des gardes fous pour protéger l'équité
de l'activité économique
il nous semble pour que ces raisons pour
ces raisons que nous devons d'abord
réfléchir un changement de méthode de
travail avant de penser un changement
statutaire sans que cela ne soit
forcément exclusive
il est en particulier nécessaire de
renforcer la dimension
partenariale entre l'État la société
civile et les collectivités en
s'appuyant sur les contrats de
développement et les contrats de
convergence
les plans de convergence doivent en
effet déjà contenir un volet sur
l'adaptation des normes
s'ils étaient élaborés avec la société
civile et notamment les chambres
consulaires qui en deviendraient les
signataires il pourrait constituer des
diagnostics territoriaux partagés mais
aussi contenir des engagements
financiers sur et et de gestion des
collectivités
nous pensons que certaines dispositions
de ces plans pourraient dès lors être
voté par le Parlement pour valider les
demandes d'habilitation
pour cela nous proposons que chaque
chambre parlementaire réserve une
semaine de contrôle par an aux questions
ultramarines qui serait notamment
l'occasion de faire le point sur la mise
en oeuvre des contrats liants l'État et
les outre-mer
ces semaines de contrôle pourraient se
dérouler en mars en amont de l'ouverture
des conférences budgétaires qui
pourraient ainsi tenir compte de leur
conclusion
ce contrôle pourrait notamment s'appuyer
sur un document de politique
transversale outre-mer qui conformément
aux recommandations de la Cour des
comptes à la commission des finances du
Sénat en mars 2022 pourrait être décalé
dans l'année pour améliorer sa fiabilité
ce document plutôt que les indicateurs
nationaux déclinés en outre-mer
pourraient recenser des indicateurs
spécifiques aux outre-mer déterminés par
un programme mais
on tiendrait toujours les états
récapitulatif de l'effort budgétaire et
financiers de l'État en outre-mer cela
donnerait l'occasion ministère des
Outre-mer de renforcer son rôle de
coordinateur de l'interministériel en
réunissant en amont de ces semaines de
contrôle les directeurs centraux
concernés durant ces semaines de
contrôle outre-mer les délégations aux
outre-mer élevées en commission spéciale
pour examiner un projet de loi
divers sur les divers dispositions des
Outre-mer ce projet de loi examiné en
urgence sous la procédure
de la législation en commission
compterait les dispositions financières
correspondant au plan et contrat de
convergence en précisant les enveloppes
de la loi des finances initiales
valideraient les habilitations demandées
dans les plans et adapteraient les
mesures d'adaptation de la législation
outre-mer
il transcrirait également dans la loi
les engagements des collectivités
locales donnant ainsi à ceux-ci une
forme une force juridique lors des
contrôles de l'égalité et des contrôles
budgétaires des collectivités locales
par les préfets
cette nouvelle organisation du travail
normatif devrait également
nous amener à réinterroger
l'organisation du ministère des
outre-mer et les pouvoirs des préfets
la Cour des comptes le dit le ministère
des Outre-mer aujourd'hui se disperse
alors qu'il manque de moyens humains et
financiers il faut renforcer son poids
interministériel ses capacités
d'expertise et son rôle d'appui en
ingénierie
les représentants de l'État doivent
également se saisir du pouvoir de
dérogation qui leur a été octroyé ce qui
pourrait impliquer la création de
groupes de liaison avec eux constituer
des collectivités et des chambres
consulaires de manière générale l'état
aussi bien central que déconcentré doit
travailler en plus des trois
collaborations avec les représentants de
la société civile et notamment les
consulaires représentant le monde
économique nous souhaitons notamment des
réunions régulières sur l'adaptation des
normes avec les préfets les
collectivités dans une instance dédiée à
Paris nous sommes représentés par Latium
et les ministères et pas seulement le
ministère des Outre-mer devrait nous
associer plus fréquemment par ce biais
qui nous permettrait de plus facilement
coordonnées structurer nos réponses je
vous remercie pour votre attention
merci monsieur le Président je propose
maintenant de passer de faire un tour
d'horizon des différents territoires en
commençant par la CCI de Mayotte madame
Nadine à
bonjour
donc je représente aujourd'hui la CCI de
Mayotte je remercie notre président
alors pour ce qui relève de la Cécile
Mayotte donc vous connaissez forcément
le cas de du territoire Mahoré et de
et de son dernier évolution
institutionnelle
nous nous sont sur une position où
nous avons encore un certain nombre de
compétences
régionales qui nous ont pas été
transférés et qui nécessite une un
transfert définitif donc c'est vrai que
sur Mayotte
on va dire que les choses ont été
précipitées lorsque nous sommes passés
départements et
sorte de région et
donc on est plus sur des
une idée de
préparer vraiment le terrain et de
rester vigilant vis-à-vis de ses
propositions d'évolution qui pourront
être faites l'avenir sur l'ensemble des
territoires sachant que pour nous comme
je le disais
auparavant
c'est celle que nous avons menée n'a pas
été complètement abouti
après je sais pas si nous on nous avait
envoyé une liste de questions je sais
pas si il faut y répondre
toutes
là maintenant mais ce que je vous
proposais madame c'est simplement de
fait ouais c'est là on faisait un tour
d'horizon des différentes CCI avec des
propos liminaires et puis après on
reviendra au travers des questions et
vous pourrez venir compléter
respectivement les pros
mes autres collègues alors se présenter
nous allons maintenant partir en
Nouvelle-Calédonie avec Monsieur David
Guyenne s'il est connecté
je suis là vous avez la parole merci
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
bonjour
Alors vous nous questionnez sur l'avenir
institutionnel des outre-mer et
notamment sur la capacité à accorder
davantage d'autonomie des territoires au
territoire ultramarins soit dans des
compétences transférées soit dans des
capacités supplémentaires d'adaptation
réglementaire et normative dans des
compétences identifiées donc l'impact de
ce de ces réformes sur nos économies
alors vous savez que la
Nouvelle-Calédonie est engagée dans un
processus de réforme institutionnelle
mais le monde économique est une grande
partie de la société civile calédonienne
considère que ce serait se tromper
d'enjeux que de réformer pour davantage
pour donner davantage de pouvoir local
sans une stratégie partagée de
développement économique et humain
l'État dans le cadre du processus de
sortie de la corde de Nouméa
à faire un bilan des transferts de
compétences en Nouvelle-Calédonie pour
le début de l'année 2023 le monde
économique lui a fait un premier bilan
et dans ce premier bilan entre décembre
2006 et janvier 2022 nous avons repris
toutes les lois de pays qui ont été
votés en Nouvelle-Calédonie sur les 200
lois de pays 40% des textes ont été
d'ordre fiscaux et notamment un
atroissement de la fiscalité 20% des
textes ont été relatifs au droit du
travail 10% ont porté sur des
aménagements de nature à faciliter le
fonctionnement de la fonction publique
en incluant les nouvelles dépenses
sociales et leur financement 6% des
textes les mesures de contrôle des
marges des prix et de l'économie 5% des
textes en excluant le droit des
assurances qui a surtout constitué
réguler les assurances décennales de
construction on s'aperçoit donc que 80%
des textes n'ont pas eu vocation
d'engager le territoire dans un
développement économique et une
attractivité répondant à une vision pour
la Nouvelle-Calédonie alors on peut se
demander pourquoi on peut apporter un
élément de réponse qui est que
l'objectif de cet accord de Nouméa et de
rééquilibrer ce qui a suivi a été de
trouver une paix politique
certains mais selon nous mon économie la
paix de demain doit être une paix
sociale et climatique apportée par la
prospérité économique durable soutenable
et partagée le monde économique
calédonien s'est réuni en consortium
pour peser dans le débat et que la
réforme institutionnelle et du sens il
vise à mettre nos administrations au
service d'un développement économique
systémique réfléchi stratégique et
concret alors les conclusions qu'on a
certaines conclusions qu'on a apportées
sont que les fondamentaux régaliens sont
ministère comme l'état de droit la
défense et la sécurité l'éducation la
monnaie que des piliers de développement
co-construit et partagé doivent soutenir
cette croissance qu'elle est donnée et
quels sont ces piliers pour nous la
neutralité carbone en 2050 qui se
décline en énergie verte et en
compensation carbone en nickel vert qui
permet de développer une économie de la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
dont la Nouvelle-Calédonie doit être le
champion océanien et exporter son
savoir-faire dans la région mais aussi
en interne une autonomie agroalimentaire
de la Nouvelle-Calédonie une économie
des tribus un écotourisme une
éco-construction
des secteurs d'énergie et de maintenance
à construire voir de l'économie autour
de l'hydrogène donc le message c'est
qu'il nous faut des sujets concrets qui
tendent qui permettent de à la
Nouvelle-Calédonie de de tendre vers un
système économique concret et qui
répondent à des besoins économiques et
sociétaux de demain donc le monde le
monde économique allait devenir pardon
demande que ce soit à l'aune de cette
stratégie économique et sociétale que
nos territoires réfléchissent à un
statut et donc ne pas
avoir la mauvaise séquence c'est-à-dire
des réformes statutaires avant même de
savoir
quelle stratégie et qu'elle trajectoire
doivent avoir nos territoires alors
comment y parvenir c'est bien la
question qui doit nous animer tous sur
le rôle de l'État la crise coïn les
défis climatiques qui vont rendre nos
territoires ultramarrage fragile
vulnérable aux fortes conséquences
économiques voire sociale je pense par
exemple à l'accueil des réfugiés
climatiques
montrent que nos territoires ne pourront
jamais faire seuls au regard des
stratégies économiques sociétales
géopolitique adoptée le monde économique
alléluia demande le soutien de l'État en
termes de cohérence de planification de
compétences techniques humaines parfois
financière évidemment pour que tous
ensemble nous arrivions à rendre
attractif et prospère nos territoires
qui vont tous devoir affronter des
mutations de modèles économiques car
pour nous en réussissant nos territoires
contribuent à une présence européenne
française impactante et utile dans nos
environnements régionaux donc ce que
l'on va vous transmettre madame
messieurs les sénateurs si vous le
souhaitez donc les travaux de MC icon
notre consortium citoyen du monde
économique notamment sur l'efficience
institutionnelle voulue et ne
proposition d'alignement entre sociétés
civile exécutif locaux état
l'organisation de nos interdépendances
au service d'une vision économique
je vous remercie
merci nous allons maintenant partir à
Wallis-et-Futuna
je sais pas si le président de la
kassima est également connecté s'il est
il a la parole président
tout
donc le président était connecté il
s'est déconnecté donc on va on va
revenir vers lui pour ses propos
liminaires dès qu'il se sera à nouveau
connecté ce qui peut arriver avec ce
type de dispositif je vous propose
maintenant de peut-être de passer
au travers du questionnaire qui vous a
été qui vous a été adressé qui était un
guide finalement pour nos échanges à
commencer par le volet institutionnel et
puis après je laisserai
shinja que sur l'aspect plus
constitutionnel et institutionnel de
cette de cette table ronde cette
audition donc d'abord sur les
compétences et l'adaptation aux normes
il y avait trois questions qui qui ont
été posées par la délégation déjà si
vous avez vous respectivement sur vos
territoires des exemples de d'action de
stratégie ou de projet économiques qui
ont été entravés ou bloqués par
l'inadaptation des normes mais j'enfonce
peut-être une porte ouverte et puis de
savoir si quand les normes doivent être
adaptés aux spécificités d'un territoire
quelle autorité vous semble la plus
pertinente je pense qu'on a commencé à
avoir des éléments de réponse avec le
président mais j'aimerais aussi vous
entendre
chacun sur vos territoires est-ce que
c'est l'état où les autorités locales et
quelles autorités en l'occurrence et
puis enfin sur l'adaptation des normes
toujours c'est dans la phase
d'élaboration des lois et des craies le
président de là aussi abordé un peu
dites-vous parfois consulter dans la
situation actuelle on a Monte pour
émettre des avis ou des recommandations
dans cette perspective si oui vos avis
sont-ils pris en compte ou est-ce que
vous considérez justement que sur ce
point ils doivent y avoir une évolution
juste avant de commencer le tour de
table sur ces questions liées à la
datation des normes de revenir à
Wallis-et-Futuna si le président de la
kassima a pu se connecter à nouveau et
si le montant surtout la parole
pourra lui être donnée pour des propos
liminaires
bon ben écoutez on ne l'avons pas la
chance de l'avoir ou de l'entendre en
l'occurrence puisque le micro semble
couper et la caméra également donc on
repart sur le tour de table si vous
voulez sur l'adaptation des normes qui
sera le premier bloc un peu sur lequel
nous aimerions vous entendre bien
évidemment et vous dire de manière
générale que nous sommes également
preneurs comme nous l'avions fait avec
la Nouvelle-Calédonie de contribution
écrite ou des travaux que vous menez
pour alimenter les réflexions de la de
l'Assemblée sur sur ce point donc vous
avez maintenant la parole on peut le
reprendre dans le même dans le même
ordre que nous l'avons fait tout à
l'heure avec le président puis Mayotte
Calédonie et Polynésie française mais
qui n'était pas connecté je crois tout à
l'heure et puis enfin Wallis et Futuna
si on arrive à avoir la connexion
Président je sais pas si vous voulez
commencer ou si vous voulez qu'on passe
directement territoire par territoire
comme vous le souhaitez
et votre micro
il y a aucun problème on peut commencer
par Mayotte sur le volet normatif
oui alors
effectivement alors nous on a quand même
quelques quelques exemples au sein de
notre chambre
sur cette inadaptation nous avons
dans le cadre de la de développement de
nos projets d'investissement au sein de
la Chambre
eu à régulièrement
demander à notre département
une participation en tout cas dans les
sociétés de projet que nous créons par
exemple là récemment c'était sur le
projet la société du projet qu'on a créé
pour la construction de la technopole
dans la commune de Dembéni et
[Musique]
les compétences régionales certaines
compétences régionales ne lui n'étant
pas dévoluer à notre conseil
départemental à empêcher que cette
opération se fasse en tout cas la
création de sa société de projet
incluant le département le l'autre
exemple client au niveau de la natation
des normes c'est forcément au niveau
agroalimentaire pour toute la partie
de de
d'exportation de d'importation de
d'aliments pour les proposer en
transformation sur notre territoire
à travers justement ce projet de
technopôle et de multilab qu'on est en
train de mettre en place un Mayotte
notre idée c'est de pouvoir
importer des produits des terrés par
voisin pour pouvoir les transformer ici
pour leur n'avons pas les les structures
en tout cas les outils les ouvrages type
que nous sommes en train de construire
pour pouvoir les mettre mettre ses
aliments et des faire venir selon les
normes européennes et pouvoir les
transformer et apposer les normes
européennes ce qui est pour nous
lorsque c'est
au niveau de la pertinence sur la
compétence
la compétence
à exercer aussi bien au service des
concentré ou exécutif pour nous ça
dépend du sujet on peut pas on peut pas
dire d'entrée de jeu voilà c'est plus ça
nous en plus pertinents que ce soit
l'état et ses services des concentrés ou
des autorités locales et pour nous et
puis au final
quand ici au niveau local un projet de
loi et de décret et soumis et qui
concerne le volet économique notre volet
celui sur lequel nous travaillons
vous leur au niveau de la Chambre de
commerce on n'a jamais vraiment été
consulté toujours un peu isolés de ce
type de décision et évidemment on trouve
ça dommage parce que nous représentants
les entreprises sur le territoire et
nous avons les éléments nécessaires pour
pouvoir
apporter les adaptations
qui vont bien
merci je laisse la parole maintenant à
la Nouvelle-Calédonie sur ce sujet
normatif
merci alors on a une position un petit
peu différente et notamment parce que on
le monde économique a vraiment
l'ambition de faire de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie un champion régional
de l'économie de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique de de l'énergie
et de de tout ce qui est
décarbonation et toute cette économie
qu'on veut faire autour de d'une vraie
cohérence de la Nouvelle-Calédonie et là
on s'aperçoit que au contraire on a
besoin d'avoir des normes supérieures
fortes et notamment celle de l'Union
européenne pour que
le dans notre région dans notre région
Pacifique l'Union européenne qui elle a
un vrai pouvoir de négociation un vrai
pouvoir d'imposer des normes elle puisse
nous ouvrir des marchés commerciaux
elles puissent notamment avoir
à la fois des accès de territoire mais
aussi évidemment à négocier des
moins de protection non tarifaires dans
la région et on pense notamment à le
voisin australien néerlandais pour que
justement nos entreprises soient en
capacité de pouvoir aller conquérir pour
la France pour l'Europe pour le
rayonnement de l'Indopacifique aller
conquérir concrètement ces régions du
Pacifique et Cécile du Pacifique donc
pour ça laquelle est Denise sera jamais
assez forte pour aller négocier
de d'égal à égal avec avec des avec nos
grands voisins en revanche l'Union
européenne peut nous permettre de le
faire ensuite moi je voulais illustrer
en fait des droits qui ont été transmis
des compétences qui ont été transmis en
totalité à la Nouvelle-Calédonie
d'accord je pense notamment aux droits
des assurances je pense aux normes de
construction et je pense aux droits
commercial et en fait oui il faut qu'il
y ait peut-être une adaptation
locale mais on a
souffert nous de ne pas avoir les
compétences pour pouvoir travailler sur
sur ces éléments structurants de
l'économie et donc si on prend notre
droit commercial il n'a pas évolué
depuis 45 ans si on prend le droit des
assurances on est aujourd'hui dans une
une absurdité de d'être nous
à mutualiser sur un tout petit
territoire alors que le principe même de
l'assurance c'est de mutualiser avec le
plus de monde possible et notamment par
exemple avec la métropole si on prend
les normes de construction là encore il
y a des
nécessité de pouvoir
combiné nord-union européenne et norme
australienne néo-zélandaise pour pouvoir
commercer et pouvoir construire et
échanger dans la région donc nous notre
proposition c'est que s'il doit y avoir
une adaptation parce que elle peut être
importante elle peut être utile que les
textes
d'emblés automatiquement soit transféré
de la métropole au territoire mais qu'en
revanche les territoires et la faculté
de dire je me donne pour chaque texte
transféré 6 mois un an pour pouvoir le
réviser mais que ce soit dans ce sens et
pas transférer au territoire pour
qu'ensuite il fasse tourner leur turbine
législatives voilà
merci beaucoup et dans la mesure où la
Polynésie française n'a pas réussi à se
connecter nous pouvons partir à
Wallis-et-Futuna puisque le directeur
général de la kassima lui a réussi à se
connecter une seule directeur général
vous avez la parole
je crois que le président est connecté
également c'est ce qu'on pensait
également mais on n'arrive pas à voir
cette connexion donc si le président de
la kassima de Wallis s'est connecté il a
évidemment la parole
donc à contraire c'est vous qui la
prenez
absolument vous entendre
un petit peu sur
l'institutionnel sur son territoire
effectivement
vous savez la partie la particularité de
notre territoire parce que bon on est on
est quand même soumise à
trois pouvoirs ici donc l'état coutumier
et puis la religion catholique donc
actuellement on a on est on est
en fait on a envie avec une division
coûte lumière donc c'est ce qui c'est ce
qui fait un petit peu le la difficulté
des de nos de la progression sur tout ce
qui est niveau économique parce qu'il
faut qu'on propose avec tout ça donc ça
ça ralentit un petit peu le le notre
développement suite à ces divisions
populaires c'était une particularité sur
notre territoire et
et là dessus effectivement
il y a ce problème là mais aussi on a on
a aussi cette certitude particularité
que l'exécutif ici n'est pas n'est pas
encore
[Musique]
n'appartient pas au territoire mais
encore à l'état donc du coup la
difficulté encore de prendre finalement
les décisions
finales sur le territoire sur un
développement
du territoire puisqu'on n'est pas on n'a
pas la main dessus donc voilà voilà
actuellement les difficultés les
difficultés qu'on vivent mais avec ça
donc
le monde économique
et essayer d'avancer malgré tout avec
tout ça mais en espérant mettre en place
puisqu'on travaille dessus c'est ce
qu'on espère c'est de mettre en place
une
un système d'accompagnement
d'accompagnement pour
petit à petit mettre en place cette
exécutif
on respecte justement les décisions les
les doigts depuis 2003 normalement que
les collectivités doivent être autonome
avec les voilà
vis-à-vis de l'institution
merci monsieur le Président je vais
revenir maintenant on va passer au
deuxième bloc sur le volet sur le volet
du bilan institutionnel
notamment en matière de gouvernance
est-ce que la gouvernance actuelle dans
chacun de vos territoires vous paraît
suffisamment lisible pour le monde
économique on a commencé à avoir des
éléments de réponse intéressant et
j'aimerais pouvoir vous entendre sur ce
sujet avez-vous relevé soit des conflits
ou ce qu'on appelle communément des 100
chevêtement de compétences entre les
différentes strates qui empêchent ou qui
nuisent justement au développement
économique de vos territoires et que
vous avez vécu au travers de vos
chambres consulaires et puis il y a
maintenant une dizaine d'années la
Guyane à Martinique et Mayotte ont
changé de gouvernance
avec la création d'une collectivité
unique ou la départementalisation pour
Mayotte évidemment cela s'est-il traduit
pour le monde économique par une
amélioration des politiques publiques au
service de ce développement donc voilà
je voulais vous entendre sur ces deux
aspects qui relèvent de la question
numéro 5 et la question numéro 6 qui
vous a été adressée et je vais peut-être
commencer tout de suite avec Madame
hafidou de Mayotte à moins que le
président Robert vous vouliez peut-être
intervenir sur sur ce sujet là
si c'est le cas Président vous avez la
parole
oui président oui donc
en ce qui concerne notre territoire à la
réunion sur ce sur ces deux sujets nous
n'avons pas forcément
trop de problématiques
liés au
aux différents
étages de compétences de chacun en
l'occurrence des des collectivités
départements ou région mais je voudrais
quand même revenir
sur le sujet tout à l'heure qui était
Mayotte comme Mayotte je pense qui on
est dans une problématique où il faut
vraiment
faciliter les échanges il faudrait
améliorer certaines normes sur notre
territoire je pense que là c'est assez
semblable à Mayotte et la réglementation
aussi qui on doit apporter une une
adaptation prend un exemple qui est
assez important et sur le sujet de
l'environnement la question des
traitements des déchets de la zone Océan
Indien il faudrait
par exemple revoir cette convention qui
existe cette convention de base
et comme
aussi au niveau de la Nouvelle-Calédonie
une adaptation des normes du niveau du
BTP qui est il nous semble nécessaire
qui
on doit associer je dirais les
différents acteurs pour adapter par
rapport à cela une norme qui correspond
vraiment à notre à notre environnement
et notre situation
et donc
à ce sujet de la question 4 et 5
faudrait je pense que nous sommes assez
notre position est assez
simple en ce qui concerne les différents
actuels qui sont concernés le
département et la région réunion qui ont
déjà
travaillé dans ce
merci merci Président on passe
maintenant sur le volet
organisation des institutions et impact
sur le développement économique tels que
ressenti par vos différentes champs de
consulaires peut-être madame afidou à la
Mayotte
oui alors
déjà pour nous
il y a une simplification qui doit être
poursuivi et je prendrai déjà d'exemple
qui nous concerne directement du guichet
unique des formalités qui donc qui
vraiment un premier pas vers la
simplification malgré après le sujet de
de la plateforme numérique c'est quelque
chose à part compte tenu de la de
l'électronisme de notre territoire mais
le fait d'avoir créé ce guichet unique
pour les formalités et ne pas disperser
ces démarches un peu partout déjà c'est
quelque chose d'appréciable pour les
entreprises et c'est comme ça que des
choses doivent aller
nous on a constaté
au niveau de ce qui est de
l'enchevêtrement un peu des compétences
des difficultés sur
l'aide aux entreprises en difficulté
justement on a plusieurs instances
actuellement on a le codéfique et porté
par l'État on a des aides économiques
qui sont gérées par le Conseil
départemental mais sans lien forcément
direct entre entre ces structures et et
les entreprises pour elles
enfin c'est pas lisible et ça nous a
mené
récemment à réfléchir à la création d'un
CIP pour centraliser
ces acteurs de la de la compagnement aux
entreprises en difficulté et qui
permettra encore une fois d'avoir une
entrée unique pour ces entreprises en
difficulté et compte tenu des actualités
des dernières activités c'est quelque
chose qui permettra de qui apportera
quelque chose au développement
économique en tout cas à ces entreprises
à s'en sortir
donc pour
ce qui est je voulais je voulais quand
même rajouter aussi sur la problématique
de des de la des transferts de
compétences qu'on achevés un phénomène
qui fait que
l'ensemble des grands projets
structurants du territoire sont
malheureusement portés sont portés par
l'État
malheureusement mais
à contrario des régions comme comme
celle de la Réunion qui est notre
voisine qui qui porte de très grands
projets structurants comme la route de
littoral etc
nous les les compétences que nous
allions pas totalement été transférées
des projets comme l'aéroport comme les
grands collèges qu'on nous construisons
comme la route de contournement que nous
faisons faire sur mamansou
ne sont pas portés par par la région en
tout cas ont du mal à être porter
donc par manque de compétences de moyens
et
voilà c'est pas favorable non plus à un
développement serein
merci Madame on passe maintenant la
Nouvelle-Calédonie monsieur Guyane
oui merci alors alors la
Nouvelle-Calédonie elle a
entamée et très largement ce processus
de transfert de compétence et on peut
dire quand même que le début des accords
le début de la période des accords a
permis de
professionnaliser de faire émerger une
un vrai rééquilibrage à la fois
politique économique mais aussi un vrai
rééquilibrage de compétences pour gérer
une collectivité donc ça c'était au
début et en fait le problème c'est que
aujourd'hui
on est
on a dérivé et on se retrouve avec des
une classe en tout cas une organisation
politique qui
ne
ne traite que de politique politicienne
je suis désolé de dire de aussi
et que donc
on a même on arrive même à des
situations
des projets de loi parfois même
économiques vont être torpillés par les
uns ou par les autres logiquement pour
des objectifs politiques pour ça
évidemment dans un petit pays comme la
Nouvelle-Calédonie que il est plus
possible ce n'est plus possible et les
effets on les voit de manière très
concrète vous donnez deux exemples
d'abord le les compétences
ont été trop pas assez précisément
défini et notamment on a coutume de dire
que les provinces
en charge le développement économique de
la qualité chaque province et du coup on
se retrouve avec
des provinces qui vont toucher à tout en
économie parce que pour elle l'économie
ça veut dire tout ce qui a trait à au
monétaire tout ce qui a trait un petit
peu à
aux entreprises mais on oublie envie de
dire que l'économie il y a de la
macroéconomie et la macroéconomie doit
rester au niveau de l'État la monnaie
etc et il y a la politique monétaire et
il y a de la microéconomie ou là
effectivement c'est à nous dans nos
territoires de pouvoir aller travailler
avec les administrations pour justement
avoir ce lien entre administration
entreprise administration citoyen donc
ça c'est mal défini des principes de
subsidiarité aussi sont mal définis en
Nouvelle-Calédonie entre le gouvernement
les provinces
on va revenir à la Nouvelle-Calédonie
comme chez Guyenne aura réussi à se
reconnecter on sait ce qu'on appelle un
arrêt sur image donc je vous propose
maintenant de passer à Wallis et futunam
se présente vous avez la parole sur sur
ces éléments avant que nous redonnions
la parole à Monsieur Guyenne sur le
volet sur le volet de l'organisation des
institutions et puis surtout comment le
monde économique voit ou pas ou a vécu
des conflits ou des enchantements de
compétences par rapport au développement
économique
alors si le président de la kassima de
Wallis-et-Futuna n'est pas de la Ccima
n'est pas disponible peut-être que
Monsieur Hersan pourrait prendre le
relais sur cette question le cas échéant
oui tout à fait je vais dire un mot sur
le sujet
pour ce qui est de la gouvernance le
président l'a dit tout à l'heure et puis
je crois que le même le président de
l'Assemblée territoriale que vous avez
vu avant là aussi évoquer
il y a un enchantement de compétences
particuliers chez nous avec un préfet
qui allait pouvoir de de
d'avant 1982 une assemblée territoriale
élue et également un pouvoir coutumier
avec même deux chefs frisky facilitent
pas les choses et la plus grande
difficulté pour le monde économique
c'est qu'on a une administration qui est
bicéphale les services ont deux chefs
ils ont à la fois le préfet représentant
de l'étage du territoire et l'Assemblée
territoriale avec des élus et
enfin tout le monde sait que quand on a
deux chefs on n'a pas de chef et c'est
ce qui rend particulièrement difficile
le service aux entreprises
donc c'est c'est une gouvernance qui est
assez illisible et qui pousse pas
vraiment à avancer mais plutôt à rester
immobile et le
[Musique]
collègue de la Nouvelle-Calédonie a
évoqué tout à l'heure le
les liens avec les partenaires régionaux
c'est un exemple dans lequel ça nous
handicap particulièrement on voit que
pour créer des relations même avec les
territoires français la
Nouvelle-Calédonie la Polynésie et a
fortiori avec les pays environnants
comme Fidji on a énormément de mal nous
on y arrive de chambre à chambre parce
qu'on est des établissements publics
assez autonomes qui pouvons construire
notre propre politique mais les
politiques entre territoires ont
beaucoup de mal à se mettre en place là
par exemple avec la Nouvelle-Calédonie
tout est bloqué depuis quasiment deux
ans pour des raisons comme disait
monsieur de mienne politicienne donc on
travaille entre chambre mais pas entre
territoires et c'est dommage
merci Monsieur le Directeur Général et
puisque monsieur justement Guyenne est
revenu parmi nous et qui était resté en
suspension je vous propose de reprendre
le propos vous n'aviez pas pu terminer
un peu plus tôt monsieur Guyane merci je
suis vraiment désolé de la connexion
donc il disait que
la subsidiarité est pas opérant ne
fonctionne pas en Nouvelle-Calédonie et
que du coup par exemple sur les
compétences on va à la fois mélanger des
compétences on va dire
institutionnelle et maintenant on en
arrive aussi à dire que le proxy de la
compétence et ben ça va être de mettre
de l'emploi local dans les
administrations dans le régalien et en
fait cette
pour nous ce sont des des dérives qu'il
faut absolument cadrer parce que
elle ne vont elles ne sont que des
réponses politiciennes et elle ne
répondent pas aux enjeux et aux défis
économiques et pour terminer je voulais
vraiment prendre l'exemple de ce qui
s'est passé lors du covid ou chacun
c'est un petit peu assis sur ses
compétences et à travailler ensemble et
le tout le monde a trouvé
pouvoir faire passer des textes parfois
en violant les compétences des uns et
des autres mais ça a fonctionné et donc
quand il y a cette urgence et bien on
s'aperçoit que on peut être imaginatif
et nous on souhaiterait que laquelle est
donnée économique soit toujours en mode
covid excusez-moi de dire comme ça c'est
à dire que elle doit avoir cet objectif
cette urgence de s'en sortir et de
trouver ces moyens pour s'en sortir et
on aimerait que sur les secteurs
d'avenir qui
sont qui ont ou qui seront identifiés
par l'ensemble des Calédoniens les
secteurs d'avenir économiques que état
collectivité et citoyens on se regroupe
pour dire voilà sur ça les compétences
on va prendre quel
institution sera la plus forte pour
diriger la compétence pour organiser la
compétence et pour nous amener à un
développement économique plus
plus fort et plus impactant voilà c'est
notre souhait c'est compliqué ça demande
une certaine mécanique institutionnelle
probablement et constitutionnel mais en
tout cas pour nous c'est une question de
pragmatisme et d'efficacité
merci Monsieur Guyenne alors mettons on
va passer à l'aspect rôle les relations
avec l'État avant de laisser la parole à
michine Jack sur le volet
constitutionnel et la réouverture du
débat possiblement institutionnel
comment est-ce que vous jugez sur chacun
de vos territoires justement le
l'accompagnement les modalités
d'accompagnement de l'État et puis
est-ce que la déconcentration permet
réellement à vos états territoriaux on
va l'appeler comme ça on va les appeler
comme ça en l'occurrence d'adapter leurs
propres politiques dans leur domaine de
compétences au domaine est-ce que selon
vous il faudrait que le préfet puisse
déroger encore plus fortement aux règles
pour les adapter à vos territoires ou
est-ce que ça doit relever d'un autre
niveau normatif voilà ce sont les
questions 7 et 8 dont le questionnaire
et ensuite c'est Michel Jack qui prendra
la main sur le volet constitutionnel on
commence à Monsieur Robert peut-être
les présidents
[Musique]
merci
Madame hafidou pour Mayotte
alors
[Musique]
pour ce qui est du rôle et
l'accompagnement d'État bon
[Musique]
c'est difficile pour nous d'avoir une
appréciation positive compte tenu de
l'actualité et des difficultés
qu'il a actuellement à Mayas a déjà
assumé ces
compétences régaliennes
santé sécurité éducation donc
pour nous ici l'état manque de moyens
forcément c'est c'est une évidence
[Musique]
la preuve principale au niveau du
développement économique c'est la
l'organisation du Haut Conseil de la
commande publique
c'est quelque chose depuis quelques
années qui a été installé à Mayotte qui
vont l'associe après la présidence mais
qui doit être géré par les services de
l'État à savoir le gars depuis son
installation n'a jamais pu le
réunir et c'est un instance absolument
essentiel pour la visibilité de nos
entreprises pour
la coordination de l'ensemble des
maîtres d'ouvrage des déporteurs de
projets publics ici à Mayotte quand on
sait que le
nombre d'entreprises à Mayotte pas n'est
pas les très limitée et quand on voit
les défis qu'on nous avons relevés en
termes de d'aménagement de construction
de
d'ouvrages
le rectorat les logements
voilà on est on a on est dans une
situation actuellement de complète
saturation au niveau du BTP mais c'est
une saturation qui aurait pu être
anticipée si
cette instance elle ses travaux est
réellement été
suivi
sur sur la déconcentration si
elle permet suffisamment à l'état de
d'adapter ses propres politiques
moi je suis mitigé alors
assouplir les conditions
pas forcément moi je reste persuadé que
le peu de moyens alloué au service des
concentrés de l'État ici leurs empêchent
de vraiment
assumer leur rôle l'accompagnement
qu'ils sont censés faire sur aux
collectivités aux institutions comme les
nôtres et
il y a vraiment quelque chose à faire
évoluer à ce niveau là
bien sûr le
tout ça tout ça corrélé à ça la lourdeur
administrative que peut représenter
certaines démarches
et comme je le disais sur les propos
précédents
de
doivent aller dans la simplification et
en particulier dans tout ce qui est volé
aménagement et
des démarches d'autorisation
administrative qui peut y avoir ça il a
sur les projets
merci nous partons maintenant aux
nouvelles Calédonie monsieur Guyenne
merci alors nous
à peu près 4 rôles de l'État alors le
premier rôle c'est évidemment un rôle
institutionnel le garant de l'État de
droit le garant de la monnaie de la
politique monétaire le garant de la
sécurité et de l'espace de nos espaces
Mère Terre et cyber et autres et le
garant de notre éducation donc ça c'est
la partie on va dire institutionnelle le
deuxième point c'est plutôt sur
l'accompagnement dans
l'autonomisation de nos territoires et
je pense notamment à l'intégration de
nos territoires dans les grandes
politiques de de transition et de
mutation évidemment sur l'énergie
évidemment sur sur tout ce qui est
environnemental et toutes les économies
qui peuvent s'opérer autour de ces
transitions
et donc cette intégration qui doit être
aussi un accompagnement sur la
planification des projets et
l'organisation des investissements des
investissements le troisième
le troisième rôle qui a un rôle très
opérationnel c'est le contrôle de
l'égalité c'est les garanties de
financement c'est par exemple les
contrats de plan et de entre l'État et
les territoires et l'État et les autres
collectivités de la Nouvelle-Calédonie
sont donc gardés cette cette ce rôle
très opérationnel pour nous accompagner
et le quatrième rôle c'est un rôle j'ai
envie de dire de sauveur c'est à dire
que on sait qu'on va toujours on va
vivre des crises de plus en plus graves
de plus en plus imprévus et ça on ne
pourra pas le faire tout seul et l'État
doit toujours être là pour nous sauver
et en tout cas nous nous aider dans ces
situations critiques
merci et nous partons maintenant vers
Wallis-et-Futuna soit le président
puisse connecter et s'il ne sait pas
comme Monsieur Hersan le directeur
général de la CCI ma vous avez la parole
merci donc je
mon directeur est complétera un petit
peu après mais effectivement
je suis d'accord effectivement
[Musique]
c'est exactement ça l'État les barons
baron de tous l'institutions donc
l'éducation à ce que monétaire et tout
ça mais après ici on a donc je reviens
aussi l'aspect un petit peu
les spécificités de notre territoire qui
fait que les relations
le territoire et l'État il faut que il y
a des blocages il y a des blocages là
dessus parce que on a on a un système
coutumier qui font que
on ne pourra pas avancer normalement
normalement et donc
là dessus
moi je dirais que effectivement il y
avait une
des années passées il y avait une
ingérence là dessus de l'État par
rapport à notre à notre aspect coutumier
et là et là on en paye on a pris les
pauvres et donc maintenant avec ça il
faut qu'on compose avec encore une fois
et là comme disait
mon directeur tout à l'heure et donc là
on stagne on stagne parce que pourquoi
parce que là on a on a des des autorités
qui
font qu'à un moment un moment ou non il
faut que il faut que qu'on développe
quelque chose donc c'est là dessus c'est
et au niveau développement économique
on pourra pas avancer comme il l'aurait
fallu il aurait fallu pourquoi parce que
il y a cette astulé et cet aspect là et
je pense qu'il faut un moment on a
trouvé la solution pour régler d'abord
cette division et ensuite
ensuite pourra on pourra après
refaire un petit
reparler d'un développement
qui pourra en sorte qu'on arrive à
avancer correctement voilà je laisse mon
directeur complété mais mes propos
si Monsieur le Directeur voulait prendre
la parole pour compléter les protons du
Président vous l'avez sinon on va passer
à la deuxième partie de la Table Ronde
juste
la question porte sur la déconcentration
comme il n'y a pas de déconcentration
chez nous évidemment c'est un peu
voilà limité et on a
encore une fois le
[Musique]
l'accompagnement de l'État ne porte pas
suffisamment sur l'économie c'est un
fait malgré la succession des préfets
voilà c'est tout ce que j'aurais à dire
merci beaucoup
merci Président mes chers collègues
madame messieurs je
m'orienterai vers le débat
constitutionnel déjà permettez-moi de
faire remarquer que les les
interventions de chacun montrent déjà
que chaque territoire est unique assez
spécificités et qu'il est ce qui est
valable dans un territoire ou ce qui est
réclamé dans un territoire ne l'est pas
force forcément pour l'autre donc c'est
ce qui rend aussi nos travaux très
riches je ma première question se
dirigerait à l'appel de France comment
l'avez-vous
interprété et accueilli cet appel de
Fort-de-France
Monsieur Robert
nous nous sommes ça dépend des gens où
on se place sur le territoire que les
territoires et moi je considère que
c'est l'expression même de
certains élus et
pas nécessairement l'ensemble des élus
il y a par contre l'Islas un sentiment
commun d'une politique plus proche des
réalités de nos territoires ça c'est
c'est une vraie certitude je considère
que qu'il faut optimiser l'action
publique qui est nécessaire pour lever
des freins qui sont vraiment
bloquants sur le territoire maintenant
encore une fois l'appel l'appel de
Fort-de-France c'est c'est un sujet sur
lequel
certains élus se sont positionnés et
néanmoins il savait que
nous ne sommes pas tous sur le même
point de vue donc il faut il faut déjà
y est un moment donné un réel
je dirais une vraie analyse de cette
situation pour par rapport aux besoins
du territoire
madame
madame Fidou
oui
alors on ne repart donc cet appel de
Fort-de-France quand même comme une
évidence mais apprendre avec avec des
pincettes parce que
[Musique]
qui évolue l'évolution ainsi
sectionnelle comme je le disais en
première partie c'est la préparation à
cette évolution et mais être très
vigilant sur sur l'aspect des
engagements de l'État et ne pas se faire
voilà mettre les bons les bons outils
les bons dispositifs pour pour cadrer
ces éléments c'est vrai que comme le
disait le Président nous avons tous un
certain nombre de freins dans dans des
projets économiques des investisseurs
qui qui viennent s'installer et il est
temps un moment donné de réfléchir aux
adaptations qui a à faire pour que pour
qu'on puisse
tout simplement
importer de manière de manière saine
pour nous il y a des absurdités qui
devraient être levées comme
on a un vivier à côté de nous qui est
Madagascar qui produisent des crevettes
ces crevettes de Madagascar il faut
qu'on aille à Rungis pour les pour les
transformer alors que le territoire de
Mayotte est à côté c'est c'est le genre
d'absurdité pour nous qui font que cet
appel de Fort-de-France a un réel sens
je vous remercie
la Nouvelle-Calédonie n'est pas trop
concernée mais si vous souhaitez nous
donner votre point de vue nous
l'accueillons avec plaisir
très rapidement
nous
on a vécu
plutôt comme
un
geste politique enfin évidemment une
volonté politique mais attention
comme on l'a vécu nous en
Nouvelle-Calédonie je me suis permis de
d'en parler avec mes confrères des
autres CCI pour dire
regardez d'abord
assumer d'abord vos responsabilités dans
vos territoires avant d'en demander
toujours plus parce que très honnêtement
c'est une ça peut être une boîte de
Pandore voilà donc c'est tout ce que je
peux dire Madame
si vous nous entendez
allô
monsieur le Président vous nous entendez
Monsieur le Directeur peut-être
à faire par rapport à ce qu'elle fait
monsieur Guyenne à l'instant
au point de vue au point suivant
à la suite justement de cet appel de
Ford de France donc le président de la
République a lancé un projet une feuille
de route renouveau des Outre-mer qui
doit se conduire par une consultation
dans six mois d'un comité
interministériel aux outre-mer
qu'attendez-vous de cette feuille de
route que pensez-vous de la méthode et
comment voyez-vous la concrétisation des
objectifs annoncés par le ministre des
Outre-mer sur la création de valeur et
le développement des entreprises
Monsieur Robert
donc
effectivement
sur ce sujet le
préfet a déjà
sensibilisé réunies l'ensemble des
acteurs sur le sujet pour échanger
avancer sur les méthodes à mettre en
place maintenant
bien évidemment sur
notre territoire le pense qu'il faut
vraiment faire participer l'ensemble des
acteurs et en l'occurrence en
l'occurrence il faut qu'il y ait une
prise en compte de la situation
économique des acteurs économiques qui
soient qui soit vraiment
impliqués dans cette dans ce dans ce
comité parce que il y a il y a
obligatoirement un besoin d'écouter
d'entendre comme aujourd'hui
cette audition je pense que la mise en
place et la déclinaison de de cette
action qui a proposé le président de la
République doit doit réunir l'ensemble
des acteurs concernés
oui alors oui effectivement le comité on
doit être consulté le monde économique
doit être consulté pour nous il est
vraiment temps de changer de paradigme
des Outre-mer doit être des territoires
qui doivent très enfin de la richesse on
doit laisser l'opportunité aux outre-mer
de participer à la compétitivité globale
de la France et de libérer les
de permettre des échanges plus faciles
avec les territoires voisins on doit
pouvoir raisonner à l'échelle régionale
et non plus avoir systématiquement à
être super fusion des transferts depuis
Paris
l'idée en tout cas qui qui était faite
de cette feuille de repoussée
on a on a sur la méthode parce que les
délais sont très contraints on a quand
même des des volets à examiner des c'est
[Musique]
j'insiste sur le fait que les outre-mer
ont des avantages compétitifs et que les
liens géographiques qui peuvent leur
permettre de créer
leur permettra de réunir véritablement
dans le dans leur bassin économique
régionaux et donc prendre les autres
mères comme des territoires
d'expérimentation
dans le cadre de ces feuilles de route
renouveau des autres
je vous remercie monsieur Guyenne s'il
veut donner son point de vue
merci alors nous on a fait ce travail
côté société civile et je pense que pour
rejoindre ce que dit nazine ça prend du
temps donc effectivement les délais me
paraissent assez contraint nous on a
quand même réuni une centaine de chefs
d'entreprises plus de 1000 heures de
travail pour aboutir à un projet de la
société civile certes pas partagé avec
l'ensemble des politiques mais en tout
cas on a fait la démarche de communiquer
et de pouvoir finalement avoir un projet
cohérent et je pense qu'il satisfait pas
mal de politiques
et cette vraiment une opportunité pour
la société civile notamment la société
civile économique
d'avoir son mot à dire et c'est une
opportunité pour les territoires de
réfléchir à une trajectoire et de
réfléchir à des objectifs économiques
certains pourraient être partagés avec
l'ensemble des Outre-mer d'autres seront
plus spécifiques par rapport aux
différents territoires donc ça peut être
une vraie opportunité de faire bouger
les choses
et juste une petite expérience qu'elle
est donnée monsieur Darmanin est en ce
moment en Nouvelle-Calédonie et il va
mettre en place les premiers groupes
thématiques qui vont permettre à la
Nouvelle-Calédonie on espère de pouvoir
sortir et de pouvoir avoir un nouveau
statut et ce qu'on s'est permis de dire
c'est que attention
de commencer par des groupes thématiques
institutionnels politiques uniquement
parce que c'est ce qui va se passer en
Nouvelle-Calédonie c'est pas forcément
la bonne séquence nous on préférerait
que ce soit d'abord des groupes
thématiques de la société civile des
différents acteurs notamment éc qui
puisse faire émerger des choses plus
grandes et plus et plus fort et qui ne
soit pas contraint par des des des
contraintes justement politique ou ou
institutionnel donc de faire sa démarche
et ensuite de de donner ce travail
aux politiques pour qu'ils puissent
trouver des solutions
institutionnelles et des solutions de la
Souter donc la séquence est pour nous
importante
si vous nous entendez
inférieur et qui nous permettent pas
encore de nous prononcer vis-à-vis de
tous ces avancées
je vous remercie alors
pour rebondir sur ce que ce que vient de
dire monsieur Guyenne comment justement
percevez-vous les débats institutionnels
notamment à propos de cette éventuelle
révision constitutionnelle sur les
territoires cela crédit une instabilité
liée à des inquiétudes ou au contraire
cela ouvre-t-il des des perspectives de
développement
oui donc c'est un c'est un sujet très
sensible également pour le monde
économique mais pour la population
également
s'il n'y a pas une consultation
préalable de la population
nous risquons des réactions fortes je
pense qu'il faut et je considère que en
tout cas pour la réunion que ce n'est
pas un jean un enjeu réel de concentrer
tout le pouvoir politique sur une seule
institution ça pourrait même créer des
déstabiliser je dirais le monde
économique et nous avons
des un statut qui permet l'adaptation
des lois 73 en l'occurrence pourquoi les
collectivités régionales n'activent pas
ces dispositions avant d'envisager un
changement de constitution et tu es sur
certains territoires il me semble qu'il
y a même une volonté qui et il
semblerait que
l'État n'a pas toujours instruit ces
deux
justement excusez-moi de vous préciser
mais l'amendement vire à poulet empêche
justement les adaptations sur le
territoire de La Réunion donc ça
complique un peu les choses
totalement c'est
pour cette raison que nous nous
demandons il faut qu'il ne faut pas
prendre de risques sur le rattachement
pas de la réunion à la France
je vais laisser la parole à Madame
hafidou
alors pour nous
voilà comme je le disais à Mayotte on
souhaite la poursuite et l'aboutissement
du processus départemental c'est
vraiment le notre sujet et le
c'est des débats
institutionnels ne sont pas
un sujet que qu'on a sur Mayotte depuis
un certain nombre de temps
mais qui n'apportent pas plus
d'instabilité que que ce qu'on a
actuellement
sans bouleversement
en tout cas des entreprises des
investisseurs c'est d'avoir une
meilleure visibilité et ce qui est
attendu également pour la population
c'est de terminer les transferts de
compétences pour que notre département
en région puisse assumer pleinement et
exercer ses missions décentralisées
une fois qu'on arrive à ça je pense que
tout le monde se sentira rassuré on
pourra voir l'avenir autrement et
avancer sereine
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur
nous allons nous allons poursuivre
avec
le comme l'a expliqué dans son propre
liminaire monsieur monsieur le Président
Robert avec quelques réticences sur
l'article 64 en parlant de ces sujets en
parlant même de sujets de corruption
qu'il faut tout de même mesurer puisque
étant une collectivité
saint-martin-les-mines est une
collectivité de première régie par
l'article 74 et ayant une certaine
autonomie nous n'avons pas ce genre de
problématique chez nous et ni à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon donc il faut
quand même relativiser les choses
justement
la proposition de rédaction de Michel
Magra prévoit justement des statues à la
carte permettant à chaque territoire
d'inscrire ce qu'il souhaite donc vous
avez parlé aux construction vous avez
parlé de d'être acteur de ce qui se
passe chez vous et il ne faudrait-il pas
justement ce serait peut-être une bonne
une bonne initiative que de pouvoir
prévoir pour chaque territoire ce qui ce
qu'il a envie de décider ce qui souhaite
mettre en place pour accentuer leur
développement ou au contraire
limiter certains écueils qui ont pu être
remarqué dans dans certaines
collectivités donc que pensez-vous de de
ce projet de réécriture il voyez-vous
une angoisse supplémentaire ou au
contraire la possibilité d'une ouverture
et d'adapter à chaque territoire
effectivement mais enfin pour ma part le
statut
occurrence n'est pas une fin en soi il
faut savoir un moment donné on en compte
pour cela il faut il faut mesurer aussi
l'impact
au millimètre près comme on dit ce qui
va être écrit dans dans cette dans cette
réforme
l'impact peut être
un mot une virgule
une phrase peut tout changer sur notre
statut actuel et nous devons vraiment
être très très attentif à ce sujet là et
ne pas ne pas commettre d'erreur en cas
notre ce que nous disposons actuellement
déjà et sur la les pistes d'amélioration
que nous devons apporter et non créer
des contrats
madame Fidou
alors effectivement
ces travaux de réécriture et de
transfert
pour nous elle nécessite
elles sont on est plutôt favorables
à cela mais
comme je vous le disais au tout début de
mes propos avec une prise en compte des
de moyens indoués à ces transferts
je vais prendre l'exemple tout
simplement de de
des relations qu'on peut avoir sur avec
nos territoires voisins
si nous avions la possibilité de tisser
des liens plus forts avec avec les
territoires nos territoires
proches ça
ça nous permettrait de beaucoup évoluer
et de et de rayonner beaucoup plus
fortement dans dans la région donc
si on doit modifier
des éléments dans la Constitution c'est
vraiment de pouvoir
faciliter et d'inclure les territoires
dans les travaux régionaux et en terme
diplomatiques des inclure dans
l'ensemble des réunions qui peuvent être
mises en place et libérer un peu plus
les relations
et profiter de plus en plus de l'essor
économique des
comment dire de plutôt de d'amener avec
nous les territoires voisins dans un
développement économique plus fort qui
permettrait forcément de réduire l'écart
entre entre nos territoires et de
d'arriver à une sérénité meilleure sé
passer au niveau régional donc pour nous
par exemple
les ministères des Affaires étrangères
d'inclure l'exécutif local dans et
l'ensemble des parlementaires évidemment
dans l'ensemble des négociations et de
coopération
avec les territoires voisins et je
parlerai
particulièrement des territoires comme
celui de des Comores il faut vraiment
donner Paris
l'état arrête de négocier sans les
territoires
justement
l'article le projet de d'écriture
proposée par Stéphane Guillemer qui
figure dans leur rapport de Michel Magra
prévoit justement cette ouverture
et ces échanges avec les dans les
bassins avec les territoires proches et
le sens des travaux de la délégation
c'est de permettre à chaque territoire
de travailler et de faire remonter ce
dont ils ont besoin chez eux ils nous
n'avons absolument pas d'objectifs de
vouloir venir dire au territoire ce qui
est bon pour eux donc la démarche c'est
une démarche d'accompagnement d'être à
l'écoute mais le travail se fera sur les
territoires évidemment en concertation
avec la population avec le monde
économique aussi avec les élus puisque
la politique malheureusement mais
heureusement aussi donne des lignes
cicatrices et des visions pour les
territoires donc c'est le sens des
travaux que nous sommes en train de nous
sommes en train de mener je vais laisser
la parole à la
Nouvelle-Calédonie s'il veut nous donner
son avis merci
France effectivement la machine à triste
que
si on me parle plus d'institutionnels
ça m'intéressera que qu'un microcosme or
aujourd'hui il faut qu'on se rende
compte tous que les outre-mer
je vais y aller fort les outre-mer se
meurent la population est vieillissante
et les mutations économiques et
environnementales sont gigantesques mais
du coup c'est une vraie opportunité et
quand on dit opportunité ça veut dire
que on doit pouvoir
avoir un grand projet pour les outre-mer
un grand projet pour le citron vert et
la France et développer
une attractivité pour le territoire
notre activité fiscale une attractivité
sociétale une attractivité économique et
que donc c'est uniquement parce que il y
aura un grand projet ambitieux alors
peut-être pour chaque territoire que le
débat institutionnel sera intéressant
sera pertinent et
sera fédérateur et c'est encore une fois
c'est toute une question de séquence si
on fait l'inverse
on va on va tomber plus sur des
inquiétudes sur des incertitudes et un
manque de visibilité et nous on le vit
en Nouvelle-Calédonie un manque de
visibilité ce sont des personnes qui
quittent le territoire on a quand même
perdu 10% de la population en 8 ans ce
sont des
investissements qui ne se font pas et ce
sont
c'est une économie qui qui est en
perdition donc quand on a cette urgence
cette ambition et ensuite c'est 16
ajustements
institutionnel là ça peut marcher
pour rebondir sur ce que vous venez de
dire que que je partage parfaitement
votre analyse
l'idée de cette réécriture c'est
justement de créer un cadre de donner
une boîte à outils qui n'est pas
restrictive on était actuellement des
choses vous avez des cadres très
restrictifs avec un article 73 un
article 74 avec pas beaucoup de marge de
manœuvres et l'objectif étant justement
d'ouvrir le champ des possibles pour
permettre à chaque territoire de s'y
inscrire c'est c'est la finalité du
travail qui est en train d'être mené
donc malheureusement nous devrons
bientôt terminé clore cette cette
audition qui est fort intéressante je
vais laisser la parole à Wallis et
Futuna et puis après nous nous passerons
à une question sur la justement la
relation avec l'Union européenne puisque
vous avez fait référence
à l'Union européenne et je laisserai la
parole au président pour conclure
ils sont avec nous
encore une fois donc je
concernant
il faut tenir compte de la spécificité
des territoires et puis
le développement économique de chasta
puisque il faut pas que faut pas qu'il y
a deux vitesses donc là dessus
c'est encore beaucoup pas faire donc
quand largement sur sur effectivement
sur des sur des leviers leviers de
développement sur les deux manières à ne
pas à ne pas trop trop
c'est un besoin il y a rien besoin donc
là dessus donc c'est
ce domaine là il faut il faut vraiment
que
c'est pas trop trop de
se dire
parce que nous avons des territoires
collectifs qui sont qui sont plus en
avance et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
réellement que
tenir compte de cette population ici je
parle de Voice qui ont un certain besoin
encore de
devoir plus concrètement l'avenir et qui
ont besoin de toute cette
expérience des territoires le fait que
la Nouvelle-Calédonie à la Polynésie
donc c'est pour ça que je veux dire
c'est important pour nous d'avoir des
des exemples des leviers et il faut pas
voilà il faut pas
à deux vitesses voilà
donc je terminerai par le statut de
votre territoire vis-à-vis de l'Union
européenne donc certains territoires
sont des régions ultra périphériques
d'autres des pays et territoires
d'outre-mer et ce statut selon vous
est-il un enjeu important de
développement économique vous
souhaiteriez vous en changer ou
l'adapter
oui
et effectivement sur
en ce qui concerne le statut
lié vis-à-vis de l'Union européenne
je considère qu'il ne faut pas il ne
faut pas
remettre en cause et l'adaptation
justement du statut peut être aussi un
élément sur lequel qui pourrait freiner
un peu nos relations avec
l'Union européenne au regard en tout cas
de la politique de cohésion qui existe
actuellement et surtout des des soutiens
que l'Union européenne nous apporte sur
le point de vue
des infrastructures le financement des
infrastructures les toute
l'accompagnement que l'Union européenne
nous apporte aujourd'hui
en tout cas la réunion ne serait pas ce
qu'elle est sans sans l'Europe et donc
nous nous tenons vraiment à ce qui est
que il n'y ait pas cette perte
des reconnaissances de nos spécificités
et qui seraient très impactant pour nos
territoires de PA de vraiment
l'accompagnement si un changement de
statut entraînerait
infinie peut-être des modifications à ce
niveau-là
merci Madame infidous
alors oui donc
Mayotte depuis
2012 donc pour nous c'est un statut qui
est un enjeu très important pour notre
développement
depuis accès à l'accès à ce statut nous
sont ouverts de nouveaux instruments
financiers qui ont permis de sortir de
nombreux projets ici à Mayotte nous
sommes les premiers l'un des premiers
institutions au niveau de la CCI à
vraiment avoir recours au fonds
européens
etc et en matière d'intégration
régionale également c'est ce sont des
des fonds totalement
essentiels pour une meilleure
intégration et c'est
c'est vraiment pas de modifier le titre
de statut européen que nous avons
merci Monsieur Guyenne
alors nous notre statut j'ai
l'impression qui nous permet pas de
d'avoir beaucoup d'interactions avec
l'Europe puisque je crois que chaque
année c'est déjà bien le bénéficiant de
30 millions de
subventions sur différents sujets alors
le dernier programme l'avant dernier le
dernier programme c'était sur
l'agriculture je crois et le programme
le prochain programme ce sera sur
la transition énergétique
en fait le problème qu'on a c'est que
aujourd'hui on ne sent pas la présence
de l'Union européenne
dans le Pacifique et on ne se sent pas
nous un acteur de cette présence
européenne et pour autant encore une
fois l'Union européenne est très proche
de
si ce n'est déjà fait de conclure des
accords de libre-échange avec
l'Australie la Nouvelle-Zélande et
peut-être même de toute la région et là
on a besoin de se sentir européen dans
la protection dans l'accès au marché
dans les normes etc etc donc je sais pas
si c'est ce notre statut qui ne nous le
permet pas ou si c'est notre implication
qui n'est pas suffisamment forte
vis-à-vis de l'Europe
monsieur le président
[Musique]
nous je dirais que à la différence pour
le coup de la de la Nouvelle-Calédonie
le statut de PTOM et la présence de
l'Union européenne et un levier
important pour le développement
économique et la structuration c'est ce
qui a permis de financer des grandes
infrastructures également des programmes
pour l'accompagnement de de
l'agriculture les la protection des
ressources en eau
voilà donc c'est c'est plutôt quelque
chose qui vient au-dessus de la
politique nationale et je dirais qu'il y
a un facteur de de stabilité de vision à
long terme qui manque dans le dans la
politique au quotidien
je vous remercie je rebondirai sur la
intervention de Madame fidoux
lorsqu'elle a parlé des entreprises en
difficulté qu'il était un peu difficile
enfin qu'elle n'était pas assez
accompagnée
ma question se porte entre la nature des
relations entre les ceci homme et les
CPME est-ce que vous avez des contacts
puisque les CPME ont un rôle justement
de d'accompagnement ou d'aide aux
entreprises qui sont en difficulté donc
avez-vous avez-vous ces relations
pensez-vous que les CPME jouent
pleinement ce rôle dans les territoires
vous parlez des CPME en tant que
syndicat pas trop non
oui alors
moi je dirais que
au sein de l'Assemblée en fait on est on
a regroupé vraiment l'ensemble des
syndicats patronaux en tout cas pour
notre part
on différencie bien le rôle des
syndicats patronaux et de ceux de
l'accompagnement que l'on faisait fait
au niveau des chambres consulaires
[Musique]
après moi je parlais vraiment en plus de
de
la partie du repérage de ces entreprises
en difficulté parce qu'on a une vraie
méconnaissance sur nos territoires de
des différentes
procédures des situations de de
difficultés
à s'inter nombre de manquements en
termes de formation on peut le dire des
formations des chefs d'entreprise et on
voit au final souvent à arriver au
tribunal
de commerce des entreprises qui auraient
pu très largement anticiper si à un
moment donné elles avaient pu être
repérées en difficulté mais très en
amont et
cet aspect là de dont je parle plutôt
qui à travers le codéfi ne peut pas se
faire et à travers le département par
l'octroi de d'aide économique et
financière se fait et nous à travers nos
compétences d'accompagnement et de et
d'aide au développement des entreprises
donc il y a un maillon dans tout ça qui
manque fortement et qui permettrait de
faciliter le travail et la montée en
fait en tout cas le la dérive de
certaines sociétés et le à éviter
qu'elle finisse en dépôt de bilan comme
on voit trop souvent ici
parce que là donc
essayer au fait qu'elle n'ose pas non
plus ce signaler auprès de auprès de vos
services en difficulté ou c'est par
c'est par méconnaissance elle faisait
cette s'en sortir mais elles n'ont pas
elles ne savent pas où s'adresser pour
pour s'en sortir
oui c'est bien ça c'est bien le dernier
et c'est pour ça que
ce ci son information pour les sociétés
en difficulté qui réuniraient l'ensemble
des corps de métiers de l'expert
comptable qui suit les entreprises aux
avocats à nos à nous institutions
d'accompagnement aux entreprises à
osgard qui qui aussi en lien avec le
service fiscaux vraiment une un guichet
unique encore une fois qui simplifierait
le quotidien des entreprises et qui
permettrait même d'être un instant
une instance d'échange de dialogue pour
lui qui pour les entreprises qui se sont
toujours à un moment donné isolé face à
ces difficultés
je vous remercie je vais laisser la
parole au président pour conclure
oui merci merci Charles Micheline merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames Messieurs
au grade de qualité sur votre territoire
respectifs merci de la qualité de ces
échanges c'était important pour nous
d'avoir également un point de vue
parfois disruptif par rapport au point
de vue des élus qui sont souvent en
charge de responsabilité élective parce
que effectivement on se rend compte
quand même qu'on a aussi besoin de mieux
se connaître pour comprendre les
préoccupations du monde économique au
regard des attentes on voit bien le
changement de paradigme et l'approche
différente que vous pouvez avoir des
sujets qui sont pour nous plus naturels
dans un sens qu'ils le sont pour vous et
c'est très intéressant d'avoir cette
confrontation intellectuelle
confrontation d'idées ce débat d'idées
qui nourrit nos réflexions et je vous
propose de lever cette audition
maintenant pour pouvoir enchaîner tout à
l'heure avec vos collègues du bassin
Atlantic en tout cas merci à toutes et
tous pour votre mobilisation et votre
disponibilité
bonne journée merci au revoir